[Music]
so today we're going to cancel dr jorge
caballero
now i will confess that i struggled a
little bit with this cancellation i
wasn't sure if i wanted to spend a whole
cancellation on dr jorge given that his
offense is so commonplace and has been
covered so many times
on this show that it feels a little
redundant redundant but as should be
clear by now the determining factor for
who makes it on the daily cancellation
is not the importance of the issue
or even the entertainment value it's
just simply who has most recently
annoyed me
and given that um i saw this tweet from
dr jorge this morning and um he has made
the cut
and there are a couple things here that
really push push him over the top i
think and we'll uh we'll we'll get into
that so dr jorge is a physician with a
relatively large following on social
media whose bio says come for the facts
stay for the snark and of course
includes a hashtag uh black lives matter
the real m night shyamalan sort of twist
ending here is that he doesn't have his
pronouns listed in his bio i'm sure i'll
get around to that i hope he does
actually get around to it because we are
rapidly approaching a point where
anybody who doesn't list their pronouns
is a transphobe by default we might
already be there in fact
so in any case a couple days ago dr
jorge tweeted this
he said i would like to go into a
grocery store with my three-year-old and
not have to feel like i'm risking his
life or her life
is that too much to ask
i'd like to go to grocery store with my
three-year-old and not have to feel like
i'm risking her life is that too much to
ask
but wait there's more uh many of the
comments responding to the good doctor's
paranoid ramblings were all in agreement
commiserating with him a quick sample
tracy says i shudder when i see two
parents taking their unmasked less than
five-year-olds into a store
what are they thinking
and brooke says two of my three kids
have not been in a store or restaurant
in nearly two years honestly i feel like
my mental health will never recover from
finding out how awful the majority of
americans are about all of this
well i agree with you there actually i
think we're on the same page
marta says so it would seem for now um
so it would seem for now my
five-year-old does not remember the
inside of
places jennifer says i hear you was in a
target today in watertown massachusetts
barely any masks i was livid
could feel my blood boiling however when
i shop in grocery stores in newton
massachusetts almost everyone is masked
it's so so hard another comment says
we're in full gear when we go into
public it's just the way we do it
wouldn't it be nice if we didn't have to
and a guy named eric says our 19 month
old has never even been in a store i
feel i fear he'll be too big to sit in
the front of the cart by the time it's
safe for him to go grocery shopping with
me
and dr jorge responded to that one in a
follow-up tweet writing i feel this in
my soul cribs kids grow up so fast it
feels like the list of things that i'll
never get to experience with my daughter
grows longer by the day
now as i said
we have seen this sort of thing many
times already
but here's what's centered over the edge
for me
dr jorge's username
his twitter handle is this i'm not
making this up it is
data driven md
yes he is the data driven md he is
driven by the data which is why he feels
that he'd be risking his daughter's life
by potentially exposing her to a virus
that has a
99.999 survival rate for for kids her
age
and that actually overstates the risk to
her it's not that when she goes to a
grocery store that there's a you know a
.001 percent chance that she'll die
no point zero zero one percent is the
risk of death if she contracts the virus
but what are the chances that she'll
contract it
children her age have a very small
chance of even contracting the virus in
the first place
added to the fact that most of the
adults that she encounters are
vaccinated added to the fact that at a
grocery store she's not having sustained
close quarters contact with anybody
added to the very minuscule lethality of
the virus for her age group and for most
every age group by the way
run the calculations with all of those
percentages taken into account
and her risk of covid death from going
to the grocery store is much much much
much smaller than point zero zero one
percent
i wager that it's something like you
know point zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent though even
that is probably a gross overestimation
and this risk
um a risk so vanishingly tiny as to be
effectively non-existent has the
data-driven md paralyzed with fear
the data has driven him insane it would
seem
except it's not the actual data that has
done that to him if this data these
numbers
could incapacitate him to that extent
then certainly he would never drive a
car
the car trip to the grocery store is
vastly more dangerous for both himself
and his daughter than the grocery store
itself
he would never ride an elevator or an
airplane or cross a bridge
he'd never go inside any building for
fear of roofs caving in and floors
collapsing
he'd also never go outside for fear of
falling trees
lightning strikes
if a point zero zero etc more zeros one
percent chance of death is too much to
bear then life itself is too much to
bear
these kinds of risks are built into
literally everything you do everywhere
all the time no matter what
sometimes the risks are much larger
i wonder if dr jorge has ever been on a
roller coaster
roller coasters are pretty safe but your
chance of injury or death is definitely
greater than point zero zero one percent
and meanwhile it's a totally unnecessary
frivolous activity that you're paying
money to participate in
has dr jorge ever been to the beach
again pretty safe but there are sharks
and riptides and accidental drownings
and you could avoid the beach your
entire life and still live a relatively
full and normal existence
yet i bet he goes to the beach
doesn't think about it has dr jorge ever
eaten at a restaurant i mean before
covet
food poisoning allergic reactions
choking
has he ever gone up for a hike in the
woods bear attacks falling limbs you
could get lost you could trip and break
your ankle
you could get it assaulted by a crazy
drifter or or by bigfoot
did you know that
did you know that your chance of getting
killed by bigfoot in the woods is not
zero percent
nobody can say that it's zero percent
if you're worried about bigfoot and you
come to me and say i'm going to the
woods i'm worried that bigfoot um might
attack me do you think that that could
happen i would have to say
yeah it could happen i mean it could
probably won't it's like really small
chance but it's not impossible
and given that uh dr jorge is worried
about point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent risks he's now in the realm of
having to worry about bigfoot
actually i don't want to scare him but
even if you stay out of the woods
your chance of getting beaten to death
by bigfoot is still not zero percent i
mean technically speaking it's in the
realm of possibility that bigfoot could
break into your home right now as you
sit pummel you senseless
kill your dog set your house on fire
this could happen
the chance of that occurring is not zero
have you taken any precautions
what is your bigfoot home invasion
contingency plan
you don't have one what are you
anti-science
see these are all data points that the
data-driven md has not taken into
account it would seem
that's because he isn't driven by data
so much as by feelings
and he even says so remember he says i
would like to go to a grocery store with
my three-year-old and not have to feel
like i'm risking her life is that too
much to ask
which brings us finally to our answer
yes stock
it's too much to ask
it is too much to ask that you be able
to do something without feeling a
certain way about it it's too much to
ask us anyway it's too much to ask the
world
because we can't do anything about your
irrational feelings we can't control
that
it's too much to ask of us it's not fair
to us it's not fair that we should have
to do anything at all that we should
have to in any way whatsoever account
for adjust ourselves for work around
your totally unreasonable and paranoid
feelings
your feelings are your problem
they're also your child's problem sadly
and that's the real tragedy here i
frankly don't care if you want to huddle
yourself inside for the rest of your
life
that might work out pretty well for the
rest of society honestly
but i do care that you're doing this to
your child
who was cursed with an insane
psychologically abusive father through
no fault of her own
and that's why i really hope you do
something about those feelings
you do something not us you until then
you are cancelled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content